você trata o diabetes tipo do como bem
Primeiro vamos falar um pouquinho da
definição é uma condição crônica afeta a
forma como o corpo processa o açúcar a
glicose no sangue e na verdade ele
ocorre quando o corpo não utiliza a
insulina de uma forma eficaz quando o
corpo tem uma resistência à ação da
insulina isso leva a níveis elevados de
glicose e também de insulina no sangue
então isso pode causar uma inflamação
crônica e é uma Variedade de sintomas
sede excessiva fadiga perda de peso em
alguns casos ou aumento de peso que é
mais comum e problemas de visão então o
tratamento do diabetes tipo do envolve
uma combinação de mudança de estilo de
vida terapias nutricionais e for
necessário suplementos e medicamentos um
outro nome que eu dou para diabetes tipo
do é intolerância a carboidratos então é
muito importante se você mudar o estilo
de vida e uma dieta balanceada que seria
uma dieta rica em frutas de baixo índice
glicêmico vegetais que crescem acima do
solo leguminosas de baixo índice
glicêmico gorduras saudáveis proteínas
também é crucial cortar alimentos
processados farinhas massas açúcares
refinados gorduras processadas alimentos
industrializados e atividade física
regular com caminhada corrida natação
musculação tudo isso vai ajudar a
melhorar a sensibilidade a insulina e
controlar os níveis de glicose e se você
tiver acima do peso perder peso pode
ajudar a melhorar a sensibilidade à
insulina e controlar o diabetes e fazer
técnicas de gerenciamento do estresse
como meditação yoga terapia cognitiva
comportamental isso vai ajudar manter os
seus níveis de glicose estáveis então
tem alguns suplementos que você pode
utilizar Cromo vanádio magnésio beberina
benfotiamina carnosina ácido Alf lipoico
todos esses podem ajudar a regular os
níveis de glicose e melhorar a
sensibilidade a insulina o ômega-3 ajuda
porque o ômega-3 ele vai ter um efeito
antiinflamatório e também vai melhorar a
tua saúde geral então é interessante
você associar esse suplemento fibras
solúveis ajudam bastante alimentos ricos
em fibras como aveia integral legumes e
frutas de baixo índice glicêmico algumas
folhas também podem ajudar a retardar a
absorção de glicose e reduzir os Picos
de glicemia você pode utilizar também
medicamentos além dos Suplementos que eu
acabei de falar a metiformina é o mais
seguro e o mais utilizado o mais comum
então isso vai ajudar a reduzir a
produção de glicose no fígado e aumentar
a sensibilidade à insulina tem os mais
modernos como os inibidores do
dpp4 medicamentos como a cagli ptin e a
saxagliptina eles ajudam a aumentar os
níveis de lp1 que é um hormônio que
estimula a produção de insulina
inibidores da
sglt2 a emp glifos e tin a can glifos
mas essa deu problema então a emp glifos
ajuda a reduzir a reabsorção de glicose
nos zins e aumentar a excreção de
glicose na urina eu não gosto muito
desse medicamento dá muita infecção
urinária Mas é uma opção então é
importante você também fazer exames
regulares para acompanhamento verificar
a tua pressão arterial verificar vários
parâmetros bioquímicos e ser bem
acompanhado por o médico além de fazer
um um exame de fundo de olho anual com
oftalmologista